There's a short story by the fiction writer Ron Carlson in which a guy loses his job after 10 years at the job. His boss tells him, OK, go to Plan B. And the guy says, this was Plan B. Which is, I think, how it goes for most of us. We head off cheerfully toward Plan A, but Plan A turns out to be completely different from what we thought it was going to be. And so we switch to a backup. And then the backup plan becomes our life.
小说家罗恩·卡尔森有一个短篇故事，讲的是一个人在同一份工作干了10年后被解雇了。老板告诉他：“好吧，启用B计划。”那个人回答说：“这就是B计划。”我想，我们大多数人都是这样。我们兴高采烈地朝着A计划前进，但A计划最终与我们预想的完全不同。于是，我们转向备份计划。然后，备份计划就成了我们的生活。
A while back, I was giving a talk to about 100 people. And knowing I was going to be talking about this on the radio, I asked them to remember back to when they first hit adulthood. What is it that they thought their lives would be like? What was their Plan A back then? And I asked them, OK, how many of you are still on Plan A?
不久前，我在一场约有100人的演讲中提到这一点。我知道我会在电台上谈论这个话题，于是我让他们回想自己刚成年时的情景。他们当时认为自己的生活会是什么样？那时的A计划是什么？我问他们：“好了，有多少人现在还在执行A计划？”
Out of 100 people, only one person raised her hand. Just one. The youngest person in the room-- just 23 years old. Everybody else in the room was like, Plan B? What about Plan C, and D, and F?
在100人中，只有一个人举手。只有一个。她是屋里最年轻的人——才23岁。屋里的其他人都在想：B计划？那C计划、D计划、F计划又怎么样呢？
Today on our program, stories of the backup plan and people living the backup plan, which is most of us. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in five acts, including the story of how you decide, as your backup plan, to kidnap the child of the most famous entertainer in the world. And Jonathan Goldstein's story of how he took a telemarketing job just to tide things over for a while, and then kept it for 10 years-- finding, to his disappointment, that he was better at telemarketing than at anything else in his life. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目将讲述关于备份计划的故事，以及那些正在执行备份计划的人们，也就是我们大多数人。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为五个部分，包括一个关于如何决定将绑架世界上最著名的艺人的孩子作为备份计划的故事。还有乔纳森·戈德斯坦的故事，讲述了他如何为了暂时维持生计而从事电话营销工作，结果一干就是10年，并失望地发现，自己在电话营销方面竟然比人生中任何其他事情都做得更好。请继续收听。
Act One, It's Another Tequila Sunrise. John Hodgman tells this fable of giving up one dream for another much more ridiculous dream.
第一幕：又是一个龙舌兰日出。约翰·霍奇曼讲述了这个为了另一个更荒唐的梦想而放弃原定梦想的寓言。
A few years ago, the company that owns Jose Cuervo Tequila purchased Marina Key, a small eight-acre speck of an island in the Caribbean. And they renamed it Cuervo Nation. They applied to the UN for independent statehood. They encouraged US citizens to defect by a simple ritual of drinking a shot. They even tried to field an Olympic volleyball team.
几年前，拥有豪帅龙舌兰酒的公司购买了加勒比海一个小岛——马里纳基岛，面积只有8英亩。他们将其更名为“龙舌兰国”。他们向联合国申请独立国家地位。他们通过一种简单的饮酒仪式鼓励美国公民叛逃。他们甚至试图组建一支奥林匹克排球队。
The whole thing was a bold experiment in advertising via nation building. But since those heady early days of independence, the nation's patriotic fervor has calmed somewhat. It's now used as a place to send contest winners and a promotional lure for members of the World Press, which is how I found myself headed to Cuervo Nation last June for a series of very educational tequila tastings and how I met the nation's most prominent citizen and ambassador to the world.
整个事件是一场通过国家建设来进行广告宣传的大胆实验。但自独立初期那段令人兴奋的日子过去后，这个国家的爱国热情有所减退。它现在被用来接待竞赛优胜者和作为媒体成员的促销诱饵。这就是我去年六月前往龙舌兰国参加一系列极具教育意义的龙舌兰品鉴活动，并见到这个国家最杰出的公民兼驻外大使的原因。
He stood at the dock waiting for us as our ferry chugged over from Tortola. Shaven-headed, goateed, he sort of looked like Anton LaVey-- were it not for the Speedos, mirror shades, and red superhero cape. A satanist at spring break. Through a megaphone, he alerted us that we are now entering a party zone. As we disembarked, he began scooting maniacally around us with a tequila shot balanced on his bald head, daring us to suck it down without using our hands. This was Cuervo Man.
当我们的渡轮从托尔托拉岛突突突地开过来时，他站在码头等着我们。剃着光头，留着山羊胡，看起来有点像安东·拉维——如果不是因为他穿着三角泳裤、戴着镜面墨镜、披着红色超级英雄斗篷的话。一个春假里的撒旦教徒。他通过扩音器告诉我们，我们现在进入了派对区。当我们下船时，他开始疯狂地绕着我们滑行，头顶平衡着一杯龙舌兰酒，怂恿我们不用手把酒吸干。这就是“龙舌兰人”。
The other Cuervo representatives were there to teach us about tequila. Cuervo Man, I was told, was there to party with us. His job was to party. And just as I began to grasp the frightening yet thrilling ramifications of this fact, Cuervo Man spotted me. He pointed to his shot-crowned head, opened his arms wide, and chased me down the dock.
其他龙舌兰代表在那里教我们如何品酒。我被告知，龙舌兰人是去陪我们狂欢的。他的工作就是狂欢。就在我开始领会这一事实令人恐惧又兴奋的内涵时，龙舌兰人发现了我。他指了指自己顶着酒杯的头，张开双臂，向我冲了过来。
Cuervo Man's real name is Ryan McDonough. I learned this from the Cuervo reps, who I think were a little annoyed that I was asking so few questions about their tequila, and so many questions about the man who seemed to be their trained tequila monkey. Actually, I was told, the term is party catalyst.
龙舌兰人的真名叫瑞安·麦克多诺。这是我从龙舌兰代表那里得知的，我想他们有点恼火，因为我问了这么多关于他们这位似乎是受训的“龙舌兰猴子”的问题，却很少问关于龙舌兰酒的问题。其实，我被告知，那个术语叫“派对催化剂”。
And when he wasn't on the island, Ryan was going from bar to bar all over the Northeast, embodying the untamed spirit of Jose Cuervo. Meaning what? I asked them. Meaning he does interactive promotions designed to introduce consumers to the responsible enjoyment of the various brands of Jose Cuervo Tequila. Meaning what? I asked them.
当他不在岛上时，瑞安会穿梭于东北部的各个酒吧，体现豪帅龙舌兰狂野的精神。那是什么意思？我问他们。意思是，他通过互动促销活动，旨在向消费者介绍各种豪帅龙舌兰酒的负责任饮用方式。那是什意思？我又问。
And that's when Ryan ran up to the table with a toilet seat around his neck and a plunger stuck to the top of his head. Dude, he said. Check it out. Plunger on my head. And then he ran down to the beach and shoved sand down his pants. And then he sang a dirty song and made us do shots in teams. And then he collapsed in the surf and barked like a seal.
就在那时，瑞安脖子上挂着马桶座圈，头上粘着皮搋子跑到了桌边。哥们，他说。瞧瞧这个。头上顶个皮搋子。然后他跑到海滩上，把沙子塞进裤子里。接着他唱了一首下流的歌，还要我们组队喝酒。最后他瘫倒在海浪中，像海豹一样叫唤。
It's sort of hard to explain what he does, they told me. And that's exactly why he fascinated me.
他们告诉我，他所做的事情很难解释。而这正是他令我着迷的原因。
I mean, consider the plunger. Were it me, I might have come up with putting a toilet seat around my neck, sure. That's a natural. But then to extend the metaphor, to take the imaginative leap to the plunger on the head? Well, that's genius.
我是说，想想那个皮搋子。如果是我，我可能会想到把马桶座圈挂在脖子上，当然，这很自然。但要把这个隐喻延伸，要有那种把皮搋子戴在头上的想象力飞跃？嗯，那是天才。
By the last night I was there, the Cuervo reps realized I was a lost cause. They left me with a bottle of Cuervo Especial and went to bed. And Ryan and I got to talking.
我在那里的最后一晚，龙舌兰代表意识到我无可救药了。他们留给我一瓶豪帅特选龙舌兰酒就去睡了。瑞安和我聊了起来。
It turned out Cuervo Man and I have a lot in common. We both live in New York. Like me, Ryan is 30 years old, originally from the Boston area. Like me, he went to an Ivy League school and spent most of his time there drinking and feeling out of place. Yes, the man barking like a seal-- that's a Princeton man.
事实证明，我和龙舌兰人有很多共同点。我们都住在纽约。和我一样，瑞安今年30岁，来自波士顿地区。和我一样，他上过常春藤盟校，在那儿大部分时间都在喝酒，感到格格不入。没错，那个像海豹一样叫唤的男人——那是普林斯顿大学的高材生。
And that's when I realized that apart from some small matters of fate and several thousand sit-ups on Ryan's part, we were the same. We both came out of college with an English degree, a thirst for booze, and the absurd faith that someone would pay us simply for being drunk and charming. And in a strange but undeniable way, for Ryan, that turned out to be true. And that's when I realized I was jealous of him.
就在那时我意识到，除了命运的小小差异和瑞安所做的几千个仰卧起坐之外，我们是一样的。我们都大学毕业，拿着英语学位，渴求酒精，并荒唐地相信，有人会仅仅因为我们醉酒而又迷人就给我们发工资。以一种奇怪但不可否认的方式，对瑞安来说，这竟然是真的。那一刻我意识到，我嫉妒他。
How does one get to be a party catalyst? I asked. Dude, he said. That's what everyone wants to know.
一个人是怎么成为派对催化剂的？我问。哥们，他说。那正是每个人都想知道的。
Oh, that's my bag of stuff, my bag of tricks, what kind of props a guy in my field needs. Got my helmet. The stuffed monkeys I got at LaGuardia Airport. I've got three of them.
哦，那是我的家伙，我的伎俩，我这种行当的人需要什么样的道具。我有头盔。还有我在拉瓜迪亚机场买的毛绒猴子。我有三只。
It's six months later, and I'm in Ryan's apartment in Brooklyn. He's agreed to take me with him to a couple of bars out on Long Island, where he's doing whatever it is he does. And he's showing me a few of the things he'll bring with him.
六个月后，我在布鲁克林瑞安的公寓里。他同意带我去长岛的几家酒吧，在那里他做着他那行当的事。他正给我展示他带去的一些东西。
The Speedo I have I throw that on because it's just shocking. It's shock value. Rubber chicken, plunger. [PLUNGER SUCTION] Right on the bald head, that just-- [PLUNGER SUCTION]
我穿这件三角泳裤是因为它很震撼。有冲击力。橡皮鸡，皮搋子。（皮搋子吸附声）就在光头上，那只是——（皮搋子吸附声）
It was never Ryan's dream to have a job wearing a plunger. He wanted to act. It's a cliche, I know, and so did Ryan. But he had done some singing and musical theater in college, and this was his dream. Specifically, this was his dream.
穿成这样干活从来不是瑞安的梦想。他想演戏。我知道这是一个陈词滥调，瑞安也知道。但他大学时参加过歌唱和音乐剧表演，这就是他的梦想。具体来说，这就是他的梦想。
(SINGING) There is nothing like a dame, nothing in the world. There is nothing you can name that is anything like a dame.
（演唱）没有什么比得上一个女人，世界上什么都比不上。你没法列举出任何像女人一样的东西。
Ryan did South Pacific in summer stock and some dinner theater, but it really wasn't coming together the way he wanted it to. From the beginning, he knew he needed a backup plan, so he started looking for a job in finance. After all, what's a Princeton degree good for if not making money?
瑞安在夏季剧团演过《南太平洋》，也参加过一些餐馆剧场表演，但事情并没有像他预期的那样发展。从一开始，他就知道自己需要一个备份计划，所以他开始在金融界找工作。毕竟，如果不能赚钱，普林斯顿的学位有什么用呢？
(SINGING) --dame!
（演唱）……女人！
He interviewed at six companies, but he only got a call back at one.
他面试了六家公司，但只有一家给了他回音。
I think everyone else who applied there from Princeton, they all got offered jobs. So I called and they were not going to offer me a job. I'm like, why? Why not? And I was really, really upset.
我想所有从普林斯顿申请那家公司的人都拿到了工作机会。所以我打电话过去，他们说不会录用我。我问，为什么？为什么不？我当时真的、真的很难过。
And I thought I could change his mind or something. He's like, well, it just seems-- you know, people seem to think that you'd really rather be acting. And I'm like, why don't you leave that up to me? I need money.
我以为我可以改变他的想法什么的。他说，嗯，看起来……你知道，人们似乎认为你其实更想演戏。我说，你为什么不把那留给我自己决定？我需要钱。
To act, he needed a day job. But the day job wanted him to act. So he was stuck in New York, working part-time at a mail order Bible company and part-time at an Upper East Side bar.
为了演戏，他需要一份日间工作。但那份日间工作希望他演戏。所以他被困在纽约，在一家邮购圣经公司兼职，并在上东区一家酒吧做兼职。
Now, Ryan enjoyed a delicious beverage from time to time. And when he drank, either after his shift or sometimes during, everyone paid attention to him. He'd make jokes and balance shot glasses on his head. He owned the room.
现在，瑞安时不时喜欢喝上一杯美味的饮料。当他喝酒时，无论是在轮班后还是有时在轮班期间，每个人都会关注他。他会讲笑话，把酒杯顶在头上。他掌控了全场。
I mean, I've always been the type of guy that people would invite to parties, to weddings. Like, people would offer-- when I had no money and I was hanging out with my buddies from Princeton who all were making bank, and they're like, come on, we're going out to the bar. I'm like, I don't have any money.
我是说，我一直就是那种人们会邀请去聚会、去参加婚礼的家伙。就像，人们会提议……当我没钱，和我在普林斯顿那些赚大钱的哥们出去混时，他们会说，走，去酒吧。我说，我没钱。
They're like, I'll pay for your drinks. I want you to come out. And it wasn't even so much like I was such a great friend to these people. I was just a funny-ass drunk. People wanted the funny-ass drunk around.
他们说，我请你喝。我希望你一起去。这甚至不是因为我是他们多好的朋友。我只是一个滑稽的醉鬼。人们想要那个滑稽的醉鬼在场。
And I was just bar backing, and I would always goof around. And I would occasionally get a little drunk and dance with people. Anyway, the DJ there has his own DJ company. And he would do weddings, and parties, and stuff like that, so he took me on.
我只是在酒吧帮忙，我总是胡闹。偶尔会喝得有点醉，和人们跳舞。总之，那里的DJ有自己的DJ公司。他会去参加婚礼、派对什么的，所以他带上了我。
And so Ryan joined a shadow industry of party professionals-- the kind you might meet on resorts or on yachts, leading surfside limbo competitions, or at reunions encouraging people to dance. People whose job it is to force us to interact, to touch one another, to have fun. Because apparently, this is something we've forgotten how to do.
于是瑞安加入了一个影子产业——派对专业人员。你可能在度假村或游艇上见过他们，领导海边的林波舞比赛，或者在团聚活动上鼓励人们跳舞。他们的工作就是强迫我们互动，触碰彼此，寻欢作乐。因为显然，这是我们已经忘记如何去做的事情。
Ryan paid his dues working bar mitzvahs, organizing group games, dressing up as Woody from Toy Story, complete with a big plastic head over his own head. And then he got the call from Jose Cuervo. They were running a tugboat called the Untamed Spirit II for short booze cruises out of San Diego, and they wanted him on it. His job would be to entertain winners of various Jose Cuervo promotional contests. And it turned out they pretty much enjoyed the same things that 13-year-olds did, minus the big plastic head and plus tequila. And Ryan could drink, too.
瑞安通过举办犹太成人礼、组织集体游戏、打扮成《玩具总动员》里的伍迪，头上套着一个巨大的塑料头套来赚取报酬。后来他接到了豪帅龙舌兰的电话。他们在圣迭戈开了一艘叫“狂野精神二号”的拖船，专门做短途酒水巡游，他们想让他上去。他的工作是招待豪帅龙舌兰各种促销竞赛的优胜者。事实证明，他们和13岁的小孩没什么两样，只是去掉了巨大的塑料头套，多了龙舌兰酒。瑞安也能喝。
I was the envy of all my peers. Really, you know? And eventually, the opportunity came to do it full-time. And the tough part about it was that I was going to have to give up acting. Any pretense I had of being an actor was gone, because it was like, you know, I'm not doing it. So I was like, let's make some money doing something that's close to acting. And so I went with it.
我是所有同龄人嫉妒的对象。真的，你知道吗？最终，全职工作的机会来了。困难的部分在于我不得不放弃演戏。我曾经假装是演员的念头全没了，因为我想，你知道，我没在演戏。所以我说，让我们用一份接近演戏的工作赚点钱吧。于是我就这么做了。
Ryan had entered the party zone.
瑞安进入了派对区。
It's your lucky night here at Monterey's. We got Jose Cuervo in the house tonight. And I think the fire department might like that from Uniondale. You guys doing good? You want some complementary Cuervo samples? In other words, shots you don't have to pay for?
今天是你们在蒙特利酒吧的幸运之夜。今晚豪帅龙舌兰在场。我想联合谷消防局可能喜欢这个。你们玩得开心吗？想要一些免费的豪帅龙舌兰样品吗？换句话说，不用付钱的酒？
Yeah!
耶！
Monterey Sports Bar is on route 24 in Uniondale, Long Island. Hofstra University is nearby. But this part of Uniondale is not so much a college town as it is a college strip, a blacktop spoke of suburban sprawl with Monterey's on the corner, next to a guns and ammo shop, next to a Starbucks. Inside, its dank and cavernous, with banners advertising $0.15 wings and $5 pitchers.
蒙特利运动酒吧位于长岛联合谷的24号公路上。霍夫斯特拉大学就在附近。但联合谷的这一带与其说是大学城，不如说是一条大学带，是郊区蔓延出的一条黑沥青路，蒙特利酒吧就在拐角处，旁边是一家枪支弹药店，再旁边是一家星巴克。里面阴暗且宽敞，挂着广告牌，宣传着15美分一根的鸡翅和5美元一扎的啤酒。
I'll learn many important things tonight. But perhaps the most surprising is this-- people in bars apparently need Cuervo t-shirts and mini shot glasses in order to live. And to get them, they will do unimaginable things.
今晚我会学到很多重要的事情。但也许最令人惊讶的是：酒吧里的人显然需要豪帅T恤和迷你酒杯才能活下去。为了得到这些，他们会做出不可思议的事情。
Right now, I've got a t-shirt in my Speedos. Can you see that? Yes. Oh, you want-- hold on, I'm going to come to you. You've got to bite it nice and slow. Who's getting it?
现在，我三角泳裤里塞着一件T恤。你看得见吗？是的。哦，你想要……等等，我这就过去。你们得咬住它，温柔而缓慢。谁要拿到？
Let me set the scene. Ryan is standing at the back of a crowded bar. He's torn off his black breakaway sweatpants to reveal a very tight Speedo stuffed with t-shirts. And then-- how shall I put this?-- young women crouch down in front of him, take hold of a shirt with their teeth, and pull.
让我先铺垫一下场景。瑞安站在一家拥挤的酒吧后面。他撕掉了黑色的撕裂款运动裤，露出了里面塞满T恤的紧身三角泳裤。然后——我该怎么说呢？年轻女性蹲在他面前，用牙齿咬住T恤，用力拉出来。
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Bite it like you mean it, like cave woman. Yes! That's what I'm talking about.
噢！噢！噢！噢！咬住它，就像你真的想要一样，像个穴居女人。对！这就对了。
I hadn't bargained for this.
我没预料到会有这种事。
That was almost pornographic.
那简直是色情的。
If Ryan's not giving girls t-shirts out of his pants, he's serving them shots off his head eye level with their bras, or asking them to lick his scalp, or just rubbing up against them. Maybe it's because he seems more mischievous than predatory, or maybe it's because he comes with the sanction and strange demi-celebrity of a well-known liquor brand. But Ryan is able to do and say things in the name of Cuervo that would get you arrested under most circumstances. And his antics aren't just tolerated, they're adored.
如果瑞安不是从裤子里往外掏T恤，他就是顶着头在齐胸高的地方为她们端酒，或者让她们舔他的头皮，或者只是贴着她们蹭。也许是因为他看起来更像是个顽童而不是掠夺者，或者是因为他背靠着一个知名酒品牌的许可，带着一种奇特的准名人效应。瑞安能以豪帅的名义做些在通常情况下会让你被逮捕的事情。而他的恶作剧不仅被容忍，甚至被崇拜。
All right. Pay no attention to my head, right in your candy canes. No hands.
好了。不要注意我的头，就在你的糖果手杖旁边。不准用手。
On Cuervo Nation, I would have described him as a kind of corporate jester. But as I watched women gleefully French him and then wander casually back to their boyfriends, a better word comes to mind. He's a satyr, the half-man, half-beast concert of Dionysus, god of drunken revelry. And not just because he's got a hairy back.
在龙舌兰国，我会把他描述成某种企业小丑。但当我看着女人们欢快地和他法式热吻，然后漫不经心地回到男友身边时，一个更好的词出现在脑海中。他是个萨提尔，狄俄尼索斯（酒神）身边的半人半兽。这不仅仅因为他背上有毛。
Why don't you trim me like Sasquatch? Trim me. Trim me like Sasquatch. Take me home and domesticate me.
你为什么不把我修剪得像大脚怪一样？修剪我。把我修剪得像大脚怪。把我带回家，驯化我。
Who's Sasquatch?
谁是大脚怪？
Sasquatch? He's a hairy guy.
大脚怪？是个毛茸茸的家伙。
No, I know. You have a plunger on your head.
不，我知道。你头上顶着个皮搋子。
And if you haven't guessed already, this is the other reason I'm fascinated by Ryan's job. While the rest of the bar grind dances and flirts and watches sports on the 30 odd TVs at Monterey's, I've somehow managed to plant myself next to the single screen that's inexplicably tuned to PBS-- specifically, Ric Burns's documentary of New York.
如果你还没猜到的话，这就是我着迷于瑞安工作的另一个原因。当酒吧里其他人都在跳舞、调情和盯着蒙特利酒吧里那30多台电视看体育节目时，我不知怎么地把自己放在了那台莫名其妙调到PBS频道的电视机旁——具体来说，是里克·伯恩斯的纽约纪录片。
Ryan, on the other hand, is out there, moving in a world in which commerce and pleasure and liquor and sex are all intimately and uncritically entwined. And everyone is having a wicked good time. It's a world in which I normally don't travel, and Ryan is my ticket in. When he runs out to his car for a last minute t-shirt resupply, I realize that this is my chance to try my hand at satyrdom.
瑞安，另一方面，他走出去，置身于一个商业、享乐、烈酒和性紧密且毫不批判地交织在一起的世界中。每个人都玩得非常开心。这是一个我通常不会涉足的世界，而瑞安是我的通行证。当他跑回车里去补充最后的T恤库存时，我意识到这是我尝试扮演萨提尔的机会。
I get a tray of shots from the woman who's been helping Ryan, and I start making the rounds.
我从那个一直帮瑞安的女人那里拿了一托盘酒，开始四处走动。
Hey, do you want a free tequila shot? Do you want a-- Try one of these. It's tequila from Cuervo.
嘿，想来杯免费龙舌兰酒吗？想……尝尝这个吗？这是来自豪帅的龙舌兰酒。
Follow me. We'll go to my friends, and we'll all have shots.
跟着我。我们去找我的朋友，我们要一起喝酒。
Oh, yeah? OK, let's go.
哦，是吗？好吧，走吧。
And I do follow her. But when we find her friends, they all just stare at me. Maybe it's not clear, so I say, do you want free tequila? And they just say, no thanks.
我确实跟着她去了。但当我们找到她的朋友时，他们只是盯着我。也许不清楚，所以我说，想要免费龙舌兰酒吗？他们只是说，不用了，谢谢。
Designated driver.
指定驾驶员。
I'll throw up.
我会吐的。
Is it something I did? I can do something wacky.
是我做了什么吗？我可以做点古怪的事情。
If there's one thing that should not be hard to give away in a bar, it's free drinks. And yet as I go from corner to corner, no one is drinking off my head. No one is pulling anything out of my pants. And part of the problem is, I'm not Ryan.
如果说酒吧里有什么东西不该难送出去，那就是免费饮料。然而当我从一个角落走到另一个角落，没人愿意从我头上喝酒。没人从我裤子里拉出任何东西。部分问题在于，我不是瑞安。
And maybe I should shave my head and loosen up a little. But beyond that, what I don't realize until I'm out there doing it is, as much as I love to drink, and as much as I love Jose Cuervo Tequila, and as much as I'd love another free trip to Cuervo Nation, I feel weird pushing some big company's message that slamming down shots is a great game, that drinking always equals fun.
也许我应该剃光头，稍微放开一点。但除此之外，直到我亲自去做时，我才意识到：尽管我喜欢喝酒，尽管我喜欢豪帅龙舌兰，尽管我很想再去一次免费的龙舌兰国，但我感觉很别扭，去推销那些大公司的宣传，说狂饮龙舌兰是个很棒的游戏，说喝酒总等于乐趣。
Which even Ryan knows isn't exactly true. Because one thing I haven't mentioned yet, and probably should have, is that Ryan doesn't drink, at least not anymore.
连瑞安都知道这不完全是真的。因为还有一点我没提到，但或许应该提到的是，瑞安不喝酒，至少现在不喝了。
(SINGING) I would swallow a shot, chill it so it's not hot. Then I'll have some more, not a little, a lot. Suck on a lime. No, it's not a crime. Sometimes we all need a chaser. Want to put my tender gold in a blender. Watch it spin around to a tasty margarita. Jose Cuervo Tequila.
（演唱）我会吞下一杯，冰镇它让它不烫。然后我再来几杯，不是一点点，是很多。吮吸青柠。不，这不违法。有时我们都需要一杯解酒饮。想把我温柔的黄金放进搅拌机。看着它旋转变成美味的玛格丽特。豪帅龙舌兰酒。
Part of Ryan's act is writing new lyrics to existing rock songs that describe the pleasures of drinking Cuervo or give very precise directions on how to do a body shot. Here's an example. Quote, "Shots with or without training wheels. Cuervo doesn't hurt. You know it heals."
瑞安表演的一部分是为现有的摇滚歌曲编写新歌词，描述豪帅龙舌兰的乐趣，或者给出非常精确的动作指导，告诉人们如何做人体射击。这是一个例子。引用，“带不带辅助轮的射击。豪帅不会受伤。你知道它会治愈。”
It's a little unnerving to hear, knowing that the person who wrote these lyrics is the same person who quit drinking more than a year ago, in part because he was afraid that it might kill him. He was kicked out of a hotel in Florida for throwing a table of the balcony. In St. Louis, he blacked out in the middle of a promotion. And at Cuervo Nation, he got so loaded he cursed out an elderly guest he was supposed to be entertaining.
听到这个让人有点不安，因为写下这些歌词的人，就是那个一年前因为害怕喝酒可能会要了他的命而戒酒的人。他在佛罗里达一家酒店因为从阳台上扔桌子被赶了出来。在圣路易斯，他在促销活动中喝得不省人事。而在龙舌兰国，他喝得酩酊大醉，甚至辱骂了一位他本应招待的老年客人。
It was an older guy, probably in his 60s, and they were, like, professional contest winners. And he's talking at dinner about, like, all these other contests he won and how, like, this one was nicer than this one and blah blah blah.
那是一个年纪大点的家伙，可能60多岁，他们就像是职业竞赛的获胜者。他在晚餐时谈论他赢过的所有其他比赛，以及这个比赛怎么比那个比赛好，巴拉巴拉。
And it sounded like he was complaining a little bit about something, and I was like, why don't you shut up? It's a free frickin' trip, old man, OK? Why don't you take your professional contest winning attitude and shove it up your [BLEEP]. And the next day, I woke up, like, I know I said something awful.
听起来他是在抱怨什么，我当时就想，你为什么不闭嘴？这是免费的该死的旅行，老头，好吗？你为什么不带着你那职业获胜的态度把它塞进你的……（消音）里。第二天醒来，我就知道我说了些可怕的话。
The problem for Ryan was that in most cases, it is very bad to be caught drinking on the job. But in Ryan's case, it only made him more successful. The wilder and drunker he got, the more bars wanted him back, the more Cuervo wanted him back.
瑞安的问题在于，在大多数情况下，工作中喝酒是极其严重的错误。但在瑞安的案例中，这反而让他更成功。他喝得越野、越醉，酒吧越想让他回来，豪帅就越想让他回来。
And what amazes me is that at the time Ryan was deciding to get sober, Cuervo asked him to sign on for another 100 promotional gigs over the course of the coming year. And Ryan said, how about 150? That's every weekend, almost half the year spent in bars, tequila on his head, tequila spilling down his face. It must be like Eve working in the apple factory that's owned by snakes.
令我惊讶的是，在瑞安决定戒酒时，豪帅还让他签署了未来一年再做100场促销演出的合同。瑞安说，150场怎么样？这意味着每个周末，几乎全年的一半时间都在酒吧里度过，头顶龙舌兰，酒水顺着脸流下。这一定就像夏娃在蛇拥有的苹果工厂工作一样。
How does it feel, as someone who doesn't drink anymore, to be confronted on a nightly basis with people who might be a drunk and hurting former you?
作为一个不再喝酒的人，每天晚上都要面对那些可能是一个醉酒、受伤的过去的前自己，感觉如何？
I just don't think about it all that much because there's nothing I can do about it either way. And I just don't know. I think that's it. I mean, I can't make any judgment.
我只是不怎么想它，因为无论如何我也无能为力。我不知道。我想就是这样。我是说，我没法做出任何评判。
I mean, there's nobody that I could tell you, like, that guy needs to stop drinking, and know it for sure. I could certainly say, like, oh, that guy reminds me of me. You know, that happens a lot. But when it comes down to it, I just-- it's up to them. It's just, it's not my call.
我是说，没有谁能让我断定，那个人需要停止喝酒，并且百分之百确定。我当然可以说，哦，那家伙让我想起了我自己。你知道，这经常发生。但归根结底，我只是……这取决于他们。这不是我的职责。
Ryan's 150-day bar hop for Cuervo is almost over. His current contract is coming to a close, and he's now working on a new, very different project.
瑞安为豪帅准备的150天酒吧巡演快结束了。他目前的合同即将到期，他现在正在进行一个全新的、非常不同的项目。
I am Sonic Man. And I'm out to prove what a smooth, clean shave you'll get with the Panasonic Sonic Shaving--
我是声波侠。我要证明松下声波电动剃须刀能给你带来多么平滑、干净的剃须体验——
This is a television ad for the Panasonic Sonic Shaver Max electric shaver, in which Ryan plays a character called Sonic Man. He got the gig from someone who saw him doing a Cuervo promotion, and a lot of it's the same. He jumps around in public, accosting people, yelling at them, convincing them of the superiority of this particular brand of shaver by hopping into fountains and getting sprayed with a hose.
这是松下声波Max电动剃须刀的电视广告，瑞安在其中扮演一个叫声波侠的角色。他从一个看到他做豪帅促销活动的人那里得到了这个机会，而且大部分内容都一样。他在公共场合跳来跳去，纠缠路人，向他们大喊大叫，通过跳进喷泉里被水管喷射来证明这个特定品牌剃须刀的优越性。
Dry or wet. Or wet. Or wet.
干剃或湿剃。或者湿剃。或者湿剃。
But if it sounds as if there's no difference, think of this. First, people do not generally drink while they're shaving. And second, Ryan's an actor now-- an actual actor, with national exposure, a good agent, making decent money. So the backup plan has brought him back to his original plan, and I'm happy for him, but also kind of sad. Put it this way. I still kind of want to be Cuervo Man, but I don't think I'd ever want to be Sonic Man.
但如果听起来好像没什么区别，想想看。首先，人们在剃须时通常不会喝酒。其次，瑞安现在是一名演员——一名真正的演员，拥有全国曝光度，有好的经纪人，赚着不错的钱。所以，备份计划把他带回了他的原始计划，我为他感到高兴，但也感到有点难过。这么说吧。我还挺想成为龙舌兰人的，但我认为我永远不想成为声波侠。
The fact is Ryan's leaving something behind-- the booze, obviously. And that's a good thing. But also the Bacchanalian power of the booze, its danger, the contradictions that made Cuervo Man more than a day job, but a kind of inspired extension of Ryan himself-- which is, to say, a kind of art.
事实是，瑞安正在抛弃一些东西——酒精，显而易见。那是一件好事。但他也抛弃了酒精带来的酒神力量，它的危险，那些让龙舌兰人不仅仅是一份日间工作，而是一种瑞安本人灵感延伸的矛盾——也就是说，一种艺术。
Shots coming out. Come on, do some on the head.
酒拿出来。来吧，在头上顶着喝。
And I wonder, now that he's the actor he always wanted to be, if we'll ever get a role as good as the one he's already played.
我很好奇，既然他现在是他一直想成为的演员，我们是否还能看到他扮演像他过去扮演的那样的好角色。
Hey, throw this! Come here, throw this. Throw it onto my plunger. Throw the Frisbee onto the plunger. Pop it on. You got it. You got it.
嘿，扔这个！过来，扔这个。扔到我的皮搋子上。把飞盘扔到皮搋子上。把它弹上去。你做到了。你做到了。
That story and this week's entire program were first broadcast back in 2002. Since then, Cuervo Nation has closed down. Ryan now lives in Long Beach, California with his wife and five-year-old son. He says he's been sober for 18 years now, and he has gotten some work as an actor. Yes, Plan A kicked in kind of late. He's just wrapping up work on an indie film that he wrote and acted in called Last Night in Rozzie. John Hodgman has a new book coming out in a few weeks called Medallion Status.
那个故事和本周的整个节目最初是在2002年广播的。从那时起，龙舌兰国已经关闭了。瑞安现在和他的妻子及五岁的儿子住在加利福尼亚州的长滩。他说他已经戒酒18年了，也得到了一些演员工作。没错，A计划算是迟到了。他刚刚完成了一部由他自己编剧并主演的独立电影《Rozzie的最后一夜》。约翰·霍奇曼几周后将出版一本名为《奖章地位》的新书。
[MUSIC - EVE 6, "INSIDE OUT"]
（音乐 - Eve 6乐队，《Inside Out》）
Act Two, Why Talk? Here's a situation that many of us have been in and found ourselves confused about what to do. You start to become friends with somebody from work, and then you run up against this problem, which requires action of some sort and a new plan. It happened to one of our producers, Starlee Kine, at her last job, with a woman named Robin.
第二幕：为什么要说话？这是一个许多人都经历过并发现自己不知道该怎么办的情况。你开始与同事成为朋友，然后遇到了这个问题，这需要采取某种行动和一个新的计划。这发生在我们的一位制片人斯塔莉·凯恩身上，在她上一份工作中，对象是一位叫罗宾的女性。
We had just met, and we'd go out for drinks and stuff after work. We really liked each other, and we wanted to, like-- we kind of decided we were going to be, like, new really good friends, you know? But we didn't know anything about each other. So we'd start to tell each other things. But the problem was we were just so busy, and there was never enough time to tell each other the big stories in our life.
我们刚认识，下班后会一起出去喝酒什么的。我们真的很喜欢对方，我们想要……我们算是决定要成为那种非常要好的新朋友，你知道吗？但我们对彼此一无所知。所以我们开始向对方讲述自己的事情。但问题是我们太忙了，从来没有足够的时间向对方讲述我们生活中那些重大的故事。
And at that point, your friend Robin came up with a Plan B.
在那时，你的朋友罗宾想出了一个B计划。
She did. She got to the point where she-- 'cause she would start to tell me stories and she'd get really frustrated by how much she had to tell. And then she was, like, I'm just going to make you a tape. And so at one point, I was going home to LA. I'm from LA. And then right before I left for LA, she just was like, here you go. Here's your tape. And I started listening to it, and it was true. She started by saying, OK, so now I'm going to do my ex-boyfriend montage.
是的。她到了那个地步……因为她开始给我讲故事，但因为要讲的内容太多，她感到非常沮丧。然后她说，我干脆给你录盘磁带吧。当时我正要回洛杉矶。我是洛杉矶人。就在我离开去洛杉矶之前，她就像是说，给你。这是你的磁带。我开始听它，真的是这样。她先说：“好了，现在我要开始放我的前男友蒙太奇了。”
All right. I'm not going to start when I was a kid. But I am going to just give you a little background history with the guy thing. I'm going to try to stay as close to the truth as possible. That was a drag off of a cigarette. That's what I was doing right there. All right.
好了。我不会从我小时候开始讲。但我会给你一点关于男人的背景历史。我会尽量保持接近真相。那是吸了一口烟的声音。我当时就是在做那个。好了。
The whole first side A is all her ex-boyfriends, all the ways they affected her, and how it changed her, and just with all the little details thrown in. And it's very thorough, and it's very complete. And I definitely get a sense of the boyfriend.
整整A面全是关于她的前男友，他们影响她的方式，他们如何改变了她，还夹杂着所有的小细节。非常详尽，非常完整。我绝对对那些男友有了了解。
His name was Ken, and Ken was a hockey player. He was not the smartest guy in the world. And he could only describe our relationship in hockey metaphors. Like, Robin, it's like when you're skating towards a goal and you think you've got it, but you don't. And it's like a puck that hits you once, but you recover--
他的名字叫肯，肯是个曲棍球运动员。他不是世界上最聪明的人。他只能用曲棍球隐喻来描述我们的关系。就像，罗宾，这就像当你滑向球门，以为你已经拿下了，但你没有。就像一个冰球撞了你一次，但你恢复了过来……
I mean the whole goal of it is so nice and touching, that she wanted me to know this about her. And then she put his time into making this, like, catalog of her life so that I could know her better.
我是说，整件事的目的太美好太感人了，她想让我知道关于她的这些事。她投入时间制作这个关于她生活的“目录”，好让我更了解她。
But Tony and I would go to all these sort of like prestigious art openings, and he would always get drunk and start raving. Like, this is [BLEEP]. I could do this better. This is [BLEEP]. And he would walk around and just, he just couldn't understand contemporary artwork. And I really can't either, so I could kind of understand.
但托尼和我总去那种高级艺术展，他总是喝醉了开始咆哮。就像，这简直是（消音）。我能做得更好。这是（消音）。他会四处走动，他就是无法理解当代艺术。其实我也不能，所以我能理解他。
And we'd go to these installations, where the whole room would just be like one big dung ball, and he would scream, this is really [BLEEP] because it was. And--
我们会去那些装置艺术展，整个房间看起来就像一个巨大的粪球，他会尖叫，这真是（消音），因为确实如此。而且……
And then on side B, she has a list of the other things that she wanted me to know. And they're really, really, really small things, and they're just like, I had this dream once, and I feel you should know this. I get afraid when people are choking in restaurants. Just like tiny couple sentences, and she's got a list. And she's kind of checking it off as she goes along.
然后录音带B面，她列出了她想让我知道的其他事情。都是些非常、非常、非常小的事情，就像，我曾经做过这个梦，我觉得你应该知道。我在餐馆看到有人窒息会感到害怕。只是几句小句子，她列了个清单。她在讲的时候会一边讲一边打勾。
But anyway the one pet that I didn't have, which I wasn't allowed to have, was a dog. So I would steal the neighbor's dog Muffin, and I had this ritual. I think I told you about the dream where a woman had 82 household objects lodged within her body. And I'm still trying to figure that one out. Throw up story, don't feel like talking about it. The teeth story--
总之，我唯一没养过、也不被允许养的宠物是狗。所以我偷了邻居家的狗玛芬，我有这个仪式。我想我告诉过你那个关于一个女人身上长着82件家居用品的梦。我还在试图弄清楚那个。呕吐的故事，不想谈那个。掉牙的故事……
And then, after all that, she takes around the tape recorder and then she gets other people to talk on your tape?
然后，在那之后，她带着录音机四处走动，让其他人往你的磁带里说话？
Yes. She walks around and has people say hello to me. And she says, will you say happy birthday to my 75-year-old grandmother, Starlee?
是的。她到处走，让人们跟我打招呼。她说，“你能祝我75岁的祖母生日快乐吗，斯塔莉？”
Complete strangers.
完全的陌生人。
Total complete strangers. They're just random people on the street.
完全的陌生人。只是街上的随机路人。
I'm making a tape for my grandmother, Starlee, for her 75th birthday. Could you just say, hi, Starlee?
我正在为我祖母录一盘磁带，斯塔莉，祝她75岁生日快乐。你能说声“嗨，斯塔莉”吗？
Hi, Starlee.
嗨，斯塔莉。
Thank you. I know you're in a rush. I can see you're running. Could you just say, hi, Starlee?
谢谢。我知道你很忙。我看得出你在赶路。你能说声“嗨，斯塔莉”吗？
Hi.
嗨。
Hi. OK, thank you. I'm making a tape for my grandmother's 75th birthday.
嗨。好的，谢谢。我正在为我祖母的75岁生日录磁带。
Standby, Kevin.
待命，凯文。
And her name's Starlee. Could you just say, hi, Starlee?
她的名字叫斯塔莉。你能说声“嗨，斯塔莉”吗？
Hi, Starlee. How are you?
嗨，斯塔莉。你好吗？
Thank you.
谢谢。
So did this do what she wanted it to do?
所以这达到了她想要的目的吗？
Oh, I think so. For sure, yeah. It totally felt like the perfect solution to the problem of making friends as you get older. Because it's really, as you get older-- I'm not that old, but the thing I miss most as an adult is time, is time is so valuable now.
哦，我想是的。当然，是的。这完全感觉像是解决随着年龄增长交友难题的完美方案。因为随着年龄增长……我其实没那么老，但作为一个成年人我最怀念的是时间，时间现在太宝贵了。
And you don't get to have the same conversations that you did when you were in high school where you'd be on the phone with someone for, like, eight hours a night. Or you'd just stay up all night long and tell every single thing that's ever happened to you, and it was even less that had happened to you because you were, like, 15 years old.
你没法像高中时那样进行同样的谈话，那时你可以和某人每晚通八个小时的电话。或者你只是整晚不睡，讲述发生在你身上的一切事情，而且发生的事情更少，因为你才15岁。
And there was just so much talking, so much bonding. Bonding, bonding, bonding. And as an adult, you just don't have the chance to do that very much. And now we're really good friends. Since then, I understand all of her references. Like, I feel like I've known her much longer than I have.
那时候有太多的谈话，太多的羁绊。羁绊，羁绊，羁绊。而作为一个成年人，你没有机会做那么多。现在我们真的是好朋友。从那时起，我理解了她所有的典故。就像，我感觉我认识她比实际久得多。
But isn't kind of the point of being friends with somebody that when they tell you this information, that it happens in a conversation? That that's not the background for the friendship, but that actually is the friendship.
但成为朋友的意义难道不在于当他们告诉你这些信息时，它发生在谈话中吗？这不是友谊的背景，而是友谊本身吗？
Yeah, I mean, some can say that. Sure. But as far as the past stuff, I feel like it's not that big a difference sometimes. Because it gets to a point where you just have all these kind of bottled stories. Like, I got this boyfriend, he did this. And I have this boyfriend, he did this. And it meant this, and it meant that. And it's like why not just put those stories on a cassette tape to have someone listen to it all at once?
是的，我是说，有些人会这么说。当然。但就过去的事情而言，我觉得有时候差别没那么大。因为到了某个阶段，你会有所有这些积压的故事。就像，我有过这个男朋友，他做了这个。我有过那个男朋友，他做了那个。它意味着这个，意味着那个。为什么不把这些故事放在卡式磁带上，让人一次性听完呢？
Starlee Kine. Coming up, sock puppets dialing for steak and kidnapping as Plan B, in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
斯塔莉·凯恩。接下来，袜子木偶拨打牛排外卖电话和绑架作为B计划，芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Plan B, stories of people ditching their expectations and living inside a backup plan, as most of us do. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, When Kidnapping is Plan B.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，带给您关于该主题的各种不同的故事。今天的节目，“B计划”，讲述人们放弃期望并生活在备份计划中的故事，就像我们大多数人一样。我们已经到达节目的第三幕。第三幕，当绑架成为B计划。
Even now, I think Barry Keenan has a hard time thinking of himself as a kidnapper. He grew up in Southern California in Malibu, went to high school with the children of movie stars and other super rich people. And if you could say that he had a plan for his life, he achieved a lot of it by the age of 22.
即使是现在，我想巴里·基南也很难认为自己是一个绑架者。他在南加州的马里布长大，和电影明星及其他超级富豪的孩子们一起上高中。如果说他对自己的人生有一个计划，那么他在22岁时就实现了大部分。
It was the early 1960s. He was the youngest member of the Los Angeles Stock Exchange. He had successfully put together some real estate deals. He was making a lot of money. But he had also started drinking heavily and became addicted to Percodan and other painkillers.
那是20世纪60年代初。他是洛杉矶证券交易所最年轻的成员。他成功地达成了一些房地产交易。他赚了很多钱。但也开始大量饮酒，并对Percodan和其他止痛药上瘾。
Of course, if you're drinking and taking strong painkillers, you get very numbed out. And on a good day, you might have an hour of rational thinking-- quote unquote, "rational thinking." And then also the market had a big downturn in late '62, early '63. And my real estate deals went sour. In a period of six months, I went from earning about in the neighborhood of $10,000 a month in 1963 dollars, to trying to sell transparent window shades door to door to stores in the middle of the desert.
当然，如果你在喝酒和服用强效止痛药，你会变得非常麻木。在状态好的日子里，你可能会有一个小时的理性思考——所谓“理性思考”。而且市场在62年底到63年初大幅下跌。我的房地产交易也泡汤了。在六个月内，我的月收入从1963年美元计算的约1万美元，变成了试图挨家挨户向沙漠中的商店推销透明窗帘。
And it's 1963. You're how old at that point?
那时候是1963年。你那时多大？
23.
23岁。
So you've gone broke. You're 23. And then you come up with this Plan B.
所以你破产了。你23岁。然后你提出了这个B计划。
Well, one day I decided, well, I have to do something radical. And in my demented state, suddenly it came to me that the way to solve my problems was to get some money somehow, and it would have to be illegally because I was obviously incapable of raising money from my real estate projects and securities projects. So I came across-- kidnapping seemed like a good idea. And I put a business plan together and went to my--
嗯，有一天我决定，好吧，我必须做点激进的事。在那种精神错乱的状态下，突然间我意识到解决问题的办法是设法搞点钱，而且必须是非法的，因为我显然没有能力通过我的房地产项目和证券项目筹集资金。所以我遇到了……绑架似乎是个好主意。于是我制定了一份商业计划，并找到了我的……
Wait, wait, wait. Kidnapping seemed like a good idea, and you put a business plan together?
等等，等等。绑架似乎是个好主意，然后你还制定了商业计划？
Yes, I was very business-oriented. I never referred to it as a kidnapping. It was going to be-- it was the plan of operation. It was kind of like an underwriting, a securities underwriting. But I had to go take somebody's kid in order to raise the money to invest in business propositions. And then of course, being a good Catholic, the only way I could get rid of the sin was to pay the money back ultimately.
是的，我非常有商业头脑。我从未将其称为绑架。那将是……它是运作计划。它有点像证券承销。但我必须带走某人的孩子才能筹集资金投资商业方案。当然，作为一个虔诚的天主教徒，摆脱罪恶的唯一方法就是最终把钱还回去。
You say that kidnapping seemed like a reasonable option. Wasn't there any part of it that kind of horrified you?
你说绑架似乎是一个合理的选择。难道没有什么部分让你感到震惊吗？
No, because in my drug-induced state, you might say, I knew I wasn't going to hurt anybody, and therefore it wasn't going to be a crime, as far as my moral character was concerned. And as long as I was willing to pay the money back and was absolutely not going to hurt anybody, then it seemed like it was OK.
没有，因为在那种药物诱导的状态下，你可以说，我知道我不会伤害任何人，因此，就我的道德品质而言，这并不是犯罪。只要我愿意把钱还回去，而且绝对不会伤害任何人，那么这看起来就是可以接受的。
So explain to me who you decided to kidnap.
那么向我解释一下你决定绑架谁。
Well, I went down the list of all the wealthy people I knew and who had kids that I knew. There was Vicky Douglas, whose father was CEO of Douglas Aircraft. That was eliminated because she was a girl. Jim Mitchum knew me too well, and his father, Robert Mitchum, he was rich one month and then broke the next. And then Arthur Lake, whose father was Johnny Weissmuller-- all these people that had famous parents. And I went down the list, and finally I thought of Nancy. And of course--
嗯，我列出了我认识的所有有钱人，而且我知道他们的孩子。有维基·道格拉斯，她的父亲是道格拉斯飞机的CEO。那个选项被排除了，因为她是女孩。吉姆·米彻姆太了解我了，而他的父亲罗伯特·米彻姆，他一个月有钱，下个月就破产了。还有亚瑟·莱克，他的父亲是约翰尼·魏斯穆勒——所有这些父母有名的人。我列了一个清单，最后想到了南希。当然……
Nancy?
南希？
Nancy Sinatra, the oldest daughter of Frank Sinatra. And so then I said, of course, Junior. And of course, I say Junior and I'm referring to Frank Sinatra, Junior, Frank Senior's son.
南希·辛纳屈，弗兰克·辛纳屈的长女。所以我就说，当然，小弗兰克。当然，我说小弗兰克是指弗兰克·辛纳屈，弗兰克·辛纳屈的长子。
And had you met him before?
你之前见过他吗？
I had seen him. I mean, I knew Nancy in high school and junior high, and had been to her home several times, and knew that the son, who was away at boarding school, was sort of distant from the girls. The girls were doted upon. But Junior was always sort of like out of the picture.
我见过他。我是说，我高中和初中时认识南希，去过她家几次，我知道那个住寄宿学校的儿子，和女儿们不太亲近。女儿们是被宠坏的。但小弗兰克总是某种程度上的局外人。
How much ransom money were you going to ask for?
你打算索要多少赎金？
$240,000. I had made a list of all the money we needed both for investments and to help my parents, and it came out to $240,000. Since I was going to have to pay it back, I didn't want to raise more money than I could easily pay back.
24万美元。我列了一份我们所有需要的资金清单，包括用于投资和帮助我的父母，总额是24万美元。既然我打算把钱还回去，我就不想筹集超过我能轻松偿还的金额。
And you decided you were going to take the money and then you were going to do what to make it back?
你决定把钱拿走，然后你要做什么来把钱赚回来？
I was going to invest in real estate projects in West Los Angeles. And the specific stocks that I was going to invest in was Chrysler at the time, which was in the toilet, and of course made a spectacular comeback, and various-- several different stocks and some real estate, which ultimately became Marina Del Rey, the world's largest marina.
我打算投资西洛杉矶的房地产项目。我打算投资的具体股票是当时的克莱斯勒，它当时表现很差，当然后来实现了惊人的复兴，还有几只不同的股票和一些房地产，最终成了玛丽娜德尔雷，世界上最大的码头。
And in fact, if I had, by some miracle, had ever gotten the money and, in fact, invested it, it would have turned out the way that I had it outlined in my business plan. So the investments were actually fairly prudent. It just was the concept was a little off.
事实上，如果奇迹发生，我真的拿到了钱并进行了投资，结果会和我商业计划里写的一模一样。所以投资实际上是相当审慎的。只是构思有点偏离。
And so you were going to take this capital, you were going to invest in this stuff, and then you were going to make a profit over, I guess, a couple years, right?
所以你打算拿走这笔资本，进行投资，然后在几年内赚取利润，对吧？
Yeah, it would be about-- it was a five-year-plan.
是的，大概……这是一个五年计划。
And then at the end of five years, you were going to give the money back to Sinatra?
然后在五年结束时，你打算把钱还给辛纳屈？
Yes, send the money back to Frank Sinatra, and just imagining the reaction that he and the FBI would have when the ransom money starts coming back to him.
是的，把钱送还给弗兰克·辛纳屈，想象一下当赎金开始还给他时，他和FBI的反应。
And just explain how the plan of operation was going to go, how the whole thing would come off, where everybody would be at the end. How was that done?
稍微解释一下运作计划是如何进行的，整件事如何收场，最后每个人在哪里。那是怎么做的？
OK. It was indexed in a three-ring binder with indexes, and one of the sections was the benefit to the Sinatra family. And it would bring father and son closer together. And at the time, Sinatra was being investigated for his connections with the mob and money laundering through the Cal-Neva Lodge and Sands Casino in Las Vegas. And I thought, well, this might even help him there.
好的。它被列入一个带有索引的三孔活页夹中，其中一部分是给辛纳屈家庭的好处。这会拉近父子的距离。当时，辛纳屈正在因其与黑手党的联系以及通过拉斯维加斯的卡内瓦旅馆和金沙赌场洗钱而受到调查。我想，好吧，这甚至可能帮到他。
You mean help his image.
你是说帮到他的形象。
Yes, help his because I felt that if the public would perceive him as a worried parent, rather than a famous singer hanging out with the mafia, that would cast him in a more favorable image. And that was one of the things that I listed in the benefits to the Sinatra family.
是的，帮到他。因为我觉得如果公众认为他是一个焦虑的父亲，而不是一个与黑手党混在一起的著名歌手，那会让他呈现出一个更有利的形象。这也是我列入给辛纳屈家庭的好处之一。
You know the thing about that plan, Barry, is that in a way, it's utterly logical. It just proceeds from a premise that's so crazy.
你知道关于那个计划的一点，巴里，从某种意义上说，它完全是逻辑严密的。它只是基于一个如此疯狂的前提。
Sane people don't wake up one day and decide they're going to go kidnap the most famous entertainer in the world, who has known mafia connections, and so you're going to have the FBI and the mafia after you. Sane people don't do that, and particularly thinking that they're going to benefit the victims as well as their own family.
神志正常的人不会某天醒来决定去绑架世界上最著名的艺人，而且他有已知的黑手党关系，所以FBI和黑手党都会追捕你。正常人不会这么做，尤其是还认为自己既是在帮受害者也是在帮自己的家人。
When I asked Barry Keenan to tell me what happened when he tried to put his Plan B into effect and do the kidnapping, he's at such pains to get the truth of it across to me-- and to prove especially that the blame for the crime falls entirely on him, and not on two pals that he enlisted to help with the kidnapping.
当我要求巴里·基南告诉我他试图实施B计划并进行绑架时发生了什么，他费尽心思地向我表达真相——并特别证明犯罪的责任完全在他身上，而不是他拉拢来协助绑架的两个伙伴。
Now this story is filled with far too many details and takes far longer than we can spend here. Suffice it to say that it was a comedy of errors. In December of 1963, the 23-year-old Keenan and a friend nabbed the 19-year-old Frank Sinatra, Junior, who was performing at Lake Tahoe. Keenan accidentally left his gun in Sinatra's hotel room. He didn't have any cash to buy gas for the getaway car.
这个故事充满了太多的细节，耗时比我们在这里能用的时间长得多。简单来说，这是一场错误的喜剧。1963年12月，23岁的基南和一个朋友在塔霍湖绑架了当时正在表演的19岁的弗兰克·辛纳屈二世。基南不小心把枪忘在了辛纳屈的酒店房间里。他身上没现金给逃跑用的车加油。
During the getaway, his buddy Joe climbed out of the car into a snowstorm and knocked himself out by running into a tree branch. When they called Frank Sinatra, Senior, and demanded a ransom, Sinatra offered them a million dollars, and they tried to talk him down to $240,000 because that's what it said in the plan.
在逃跑过程中，他的哥们乔爬出车外进入暴风雪中，撞到树枝把自己撞晕了。当他们打电话给弗兰克·辛纳屈一世索要赎金时，辛纳屈给了他们一百万美元，但他们试图砍价到24万美元，因为计划书上是这么写的。
We sent Frank to a gas station payphone to get the next instructions about how to get his son back. So Frank Sinatra, Senior, and the FBI go racing down to Carson City 30 minutes away, and in about 15 minutes, John started calling for Frank Sinatra to the gas station.
我们让弗兰克去加油站的公用电话亭获取关于如何找回儿子的下一条指示。于是弗兰克·辛纳屈一世和FBI疯狂赶往30分钟外的卡森城，大约15分钟后，约翰开始向加油站拨打弗兰克·辛纳屈的电话。
And the mechanic at the gas station, who was busy and by himself, kept answering the phone. And this caller was asking for Frank Sinatra, the most famous entertainer in the world at the time. And the guy got very angry when this caller was calling back time and again for Frank Sinatra.
而加油站的维修工，当时很忙且独自一人，不停地接电话。这个打电话的人在找当时世界上最著名的艺人弗兰克·辛纳屈。当这个来电者一而再再而三地找人时，那家伙非常生气。
He thinks it's a funny phone call.
他以为这是个恶作剧电话。
Yeah, he thinks it's a prank of some sort. And so as soon as he hung up from the third time after letting John have it with four letter words, before he even gets back to his car, in screeches two FBI cars. And Frank Sinatra, Senior, jumps out of the car and says, my name is Frank Sinatra. Have I had any calls?
是的，他以为这是某种恶作剧。所以在他第三次挂断电话，用脏话骂了约翰一顿后，在他还没回到车里之前，两辆FBI车就冲了过来。弗兰克·辛纳屈一世跳下车说，我是弗兰克·辛纳屈。有我的电话吗？
And you can imagine the reaction that that poor mechanic had. So finally, one more time, John called back, and this time, Frank answered the phone. And John's told him what the next step was going to be.
你可以想象那个可怜的维修工当时的反应。最终，约翰又打了一次电话，这次弗兰克接了电话。约翰告诉了他下一步该做什么。
Barry, did it did it occur to you that the person who you were kidnapping and their family would be traumatized and frightened?
巴里，有没有想过，那个你绑架的人以及他们的家人会受到创伤和惊吓？
No, because the way that the plan of operation was designed and the way I wrote it out in the script, it was always supposed to be just between Frank Sinatra, Senior, Frank Sinatra, Junior, my group of people, and the FBI. The mother and sisters were not to be involved in the kidnapping. And based upon what I knew about Frank Sinatra, Senior, and the family, and so forth, I did not think that he would let his wife know if he thought the kidnapping was going to be resolved in a matter of a few hours.
没有，因为运作计划的设计方式以及我写在剧本里的方式，它一直被认为只会在弗兰克·辛纳屈一世、弗兰克·辛纳屈二世、我的团伙和FBI之间进行。母亲和姐妹们不应该参与到绑架中。基于我对弗兰克·辛纳屈一世和这个家庭的了解，我不认为如果他觉得绑架会在几个小时内解决，他会告诉他的妻子。
I wonder if the fact that you constructed such an elaborate web of logic with your business plan, that made the kidnapping seem so reasonable and even good for the Sinatra's, I wonder if that prevented you at the time from comprehending what you were putting them through.
我很好奇，你构建了一个如此详尽的逻辑网，让绑架看起来如此合理，甚至对辛纳屈一家都有好处，我好奇这是否阻止了你在当时去理解你让他们经历了什么。
Oh, absolutely. I had it so rationalized and justified. I had God's approval. This thing was being divinely blessed.
哦，当然。我把这一切都合理化和正当化了。我有上帝的准许。这件事是受到了神圣祝福的。
What was the sign that it had God's approval?
上帝准许的迹象是什么？
Like, God talked to me, particularly when I'd go to church, and light a candle, and be still. And I would hear God talking to me and telling me what I had to do. And he was very definite about nobody can be hurt. And I had to pay the money back.
比如，上帝跟我说话，特别是我去教堂、点上蜡烛并安静下来的时候。我会听到上帝跟我说话，告诉我我必须做什么。他非常肯定没有人会受到伤害。而且我必须把钱还回去。
As you've gotten older and sobered up and gotten wiser, does God still talk to you?
当你变老、清醒并变得聪明之后，上帝还会和你说话吗？
Oh, no. No, that went away when I got sober, and I also got psychiatric help. So when I hear voices nowadays, I don't pay any attention to them.
哦，不。不，那在我清醒后就消失了，而且我还接受了精神病治疗。所以当我现在听到声音时，我根本不理会它们。
After successfully getting $240,000 in ransom money and returning Frank Sinatra, Junior, safely home, Barry Keenan and his accomplices were caught. Keenan was sentenced to life plus 75 years, but was released after just 4 years because the psychiatric evaluation found that he was legally insane at the time of his crime. He returned to the real estate business where he was wildly successful-- became a millionaire.
在成功获得24万美元赎金并将弗兰克·辛纳屈二世安全送回家后，巴里·基南及其同伙被捕。基南被判处终身监禁外加75年徒刑，但仅四年后就被释放，因为精神评估发现他在犯罪时精神失常。他回到了房地产行业，并在那里取得了巨大成功——成为了百万富翁。
A few years ago, he sold his kidnapping story to the movie studios for several times more than the original ransom amount. He showed his papers indicating that all of his profits from the sale would go to charity and says that he agreed to a movie deal only to set the record straight about a lie that he told during his trial back in the 1960s.
几年前，他把自己的绑架故事卖给了电影工作室，价格是原赎金金额的好几倍。他出示的文件显示，他从销售中获得的所有利润都将捐给慈善机构，并表示他同意达成电影交易只是为了纠正他在20世纪60年代审判期间撒的一个谎。
Back then, he says he spread a rumor that the kidnapping was only a publicity stunt staged by the Sinatras and not a real kidnapping. Under the Son of Sam law, which says that convicted felons cannot make a profit from selling their own stories, Frank Sinatra, Junior, challenged Keenan's contract with the movie studios.
当时，他说他散布了一个谣言，称绑架只是辛纳屈一家策划的公关噱头，而不是真正的绑架。根据《山姆之子法案》（该法案规定被定罪的重罪犯不能从兜售自己的故事中获利），弗兰克·辛纳屈二世质疑了基南与电影工作室的合同。
In February 2002, the California Supreme Court ruled in Keenan's favor, clearing the way for the movie to be made. But it never was. The studio, Columbia Pictures, put the project on hold. And then in 2003, Showtime made the story into a film with William H. Macy and David Arquette. Barry Keenan got no money from the deal.
2002年2月，加州最高法院做出了有利于基南的裁决，为电影的制作扫清了障碍。但电影从未制作出来。哥伦比亚影业公司将该项目搁置了。后来在2003年，Showtime将这个故事拍成了电影，由威廉·H·梅西和戴维·阿奎特主演。巴里·基南没从这笔交易中拿到一分钱。
[MUSIC - FRANK SINATRA, "ALL OF ME"]
（音乐 - 弗兰克·辛纳屈，《All of Me》）
Act Four, A Fate Most of Us Fear. Years ago, living in Canada, Jonathan Goldstein had a job selling the Montreal Gazette newspaper over the telephone. It was the normal kind of Plan B that most of us have had at one point or another. And when he took the job, he did not realize that it would become a 10-year chapter in his life.
第四幕：我们大多数人都恐惧的命运。几年前，居住在加拿大的乔纳森·戈德斯坦有一份通过电话销售《蒙特利尔公报》的工作。这是我们大多数人曾在某个时刻拥有的正常的那种B计划。当他接受这份工作时，他没意识到这将成为他人生中10年的篇章。
When you're a little kid, you never decide that one day you're going to be a telemarketer. It's not something that you plan. It just happens, like the way going bald just happens, or the way falling down a flight of stairs just happens. One minute you're at the top of the landing, and the next you're at the bottom. And you'll be damned if you can remember each one of the individual steps that led you between the two.
当你是个小孩子时，你绝不会决定长大后去当电话营销员。这不是你计划的事情。它就是发生了，就像秃顶就是会发生，或者从楼梯上摔下来就是会发生。一分钟你还在楼梯顶端，下一分钟就在底部了。而且如果让你回忆导致你从顶端到到底部的每一步，你绝对想不起来。
All during the time I was working at the Gazette, I found it nearly impossible to bring myself to tell anyone I was a telemarketer. When people asked what it was I did for a living, I'd simply say that I was a salesman. And when they asked what it was that I sold, I would say dreams. And then I would look at them for a moment, quizzically. Then I would say that I was only joking, and then they would say, oh. And I would become uncomfortable, and then they would become uncomfortable. Then they would stop asking me anything.
我在《公报》工作期间，发现几乎不可能强迫自己告诉任何人我是一名电话营销员。当人们问我以什么为生时，我会简单地说我是个推销员。当他们问我推销什么时，我会说推销梦想。然后我会疑惑地看着他们一会儿。然后我会说我只是在开玩笑，他们会说“哦”。我就变得不安，他们也会变得不安。然后他们就停止问我任何事了。
As you might expect, the hard thing about working at the Gazette was that there was just so much rejection. Even though you were calling almost 200 people a day, 98% of whom wanted to see you dead, you still had to bring a certain hopefulness to each call, a feeling that this one, the call you were making right now could be the one. It was almost like trying to hypnotize yourself into believing that something as certain as, say, gravity didn't exist. And the next time you dropped the apple, it won't fall to the ground, but it will float up into the sky like a helium balloon.
如你所料，在《公报》工作最难的地方就是有太多的拒绝。即使你每天打给近200人，其中98%的人想看你去死，你仍然必须给每次通话带来一定的希望，一种感觉——这一次，你现在拨打的电话可能是那个成功的电话。这几乎就像试图催眠自己去相信某种确定的事情，比如引力并不存在。下次你掉下苹果时，它不会掉到地上，而是会像氦气球一样漂浮到天空中。
I would often pretend the people on the other end of the line were sock puppets to soften the sting of their hang up. I once shared this thought with a girl who had just started working there. Pretend there's a little sock puppet on the other end, I encouraged. All cute with coat button eyes, holding the phone in his mouth. She considered the logic of this for a moment. How does he talk with a phone in his mouth? She asked. And for this, I really didn't have an answer.
我经常假装电话另一端的人是袜子木偶，以减轻他们挂电话带来的刺痛。我曾与一个刚开始在那里工作的女孩分享过这个想法。“假装另一端有个小袜子木偶，”我鼓励道。“圆圆的コート扣子眼睛，嘴里叼着电话。”她考虑了一下这个逻辑。“他嘴里叼着电话怎么说话？”她问。对于这个，我真的没有答案。
In the pitching room, we all wore these headsets that were connected to computers. As soon as we hung up, the computer automatically dialed the next number so that we were always speaking to someone without respite. Our boss was a man named Ray, and if you made two or three sales a day, then you were doing OK, and Ray wouldn't scream at you.
在推销室里，我们都戴着连着电脑的耳机。我们刚挂断电话，电脑就会自动拨打下一个号码，这样我们就不间断地与某人交谈。我们的老板是个叫雷的人，如果你每天能做成两三单生意，那你做得还不错，雷就不会冲你大叫。
Generally, I found the repetitiousness of the job comforting. You're never at a loss for words. You always know what you're going to say. Because what you were going to say is, hi, my name is Jonathan, and I wanted to know if you're interested in reading the Gazette newspaper.
总的来说，我发现这份工作的重复性令人欣慰。你从不缺话。你总是知道你要说什么。因为你要说的是：“嗨，我是乔纳森，我想知道你是否有兴趣阅读《公报》。”
One time, a woman who answered the phone would not believe I wasn't a friend of hers named Christopher. Stop playing around Christopher, she said. But I'm not Christopher, I responded. Will you cut it out, Christopher? After several minutes of this, I had to hang up on her. I knew that Christopher was going to get it for that.
有一次，一个接电话的女人不相信我不是她的朋友克里斯托弗。“别玩了，克里斯托弗，”她说。“但我不是克里斯托弗，”我回答。“你能不能停下，克里斯托弗？”几分钟后，我不得不挂断她的电话。我知道克里斯托弗要因为这事倒霉了。
From my very first week at the Gazette, I was surprised to discover that I had a natural gift for sales. Whatever I was and whatever aspirations I had before I started working there, I became an instant Gazette legend, sometimes selling up to 10 subscriptions in the course of a shift. I got on the phone with people, and I made them want to listen. I joked with the men and flirted with the women. I gently cajoled them, bundling them up in my good strong telemarketing arms and tossed them up into the air where they screamed delightedly, only to land back down with a brand new Gazette subscription.
在《公报》工作的第一周，我就惊讶地发现我在销售方面有天赋。不管我在开始工作之前是谁，也不管我有什么抱负，我立刻成了《公报》的传奇人物，有时一个班次能卖出多达10份订阅。我通过电话与人们交谈，让他们想听下去。我和男人们开玩笑，和女人们调情。我温柔地哄骗他们，把他们裹进我强有力的电话营销臂弯里，把他们扔向空中，让他们愉快地尖叫，最后却落回原地，手里拿着一份崭新的《公报》订阅。
I would look around me at the other sad sacks in the pitching room and wonder how they could go on just scraping by with their two or three sales a day. Telemarketing had been my backup plan, but now I found myself faced with the uncomfortable fact that it was what I was truly good at. I got myself a lucky ballpoint pen and spent half a day's pay on a fancy attache case to put my leads in. I even had a special way of filling out the order forms that involved clear capital letters and X's, never checks, in the boxes marked Visa or MasterCard.
我环顾推销室里其他可怜虫，好奇他们怎么能每天只靠两三单生意勉强度日。电话营销曾是我的备份计划，但现在我面对一个令人不安的事实：这是我真正擅长的事情。我给自己弄了一支幸运圆珠笔，花掉半天薪水买了一个漂亮的公文包来装我的潜在客户名单。我甚至有一种特殊的填写订单方式，涉及清晰的大写字母和X（从来不打钩），在Visa或万事达卡栏里。
There was a bell on Ray's desk for when you made a sale. And when I made a sale, I had a special way of hitting it with the balls of my fingers that made it sound as crisp and clean as a glockenspiel. I always kept to the one tap per sale rule. I respected the bill, not like some of the other guys who rang the crap out of it like they were five-year-olds riding their first two-wheeler.
雷的桌子上有一个铃，用来表示你做成了一笔生意。当我做成一笔生意时，我有一种特殊的方法用指尖敲击它，让声音像格洛肯琴一样清脆悦耳。我总是遵守“每单敲一下”的规则。我尊重那个铃，不像其他一些家伙，像骑两轮车的小孩一样把它摇得叮当响。
The office manager was a man named Billy. Billy was a fat loudmouthed Greek man in a skintight Hawaiian shirt. One of Billy's jobs was to keep us inspired with pep talks. Billy would explain to us when he first started working at the Gazette, he was sitting right where we were, and that now, he makes as much money as a plumber. And that in fact, we all had the opportunity to make as much as a plumber. I'm going out and eating a big fat steak tonight, he would say, just like the way at the end of a day, a plumber does.
办公室经理是个叫比利的人。比利是个穿着紧身夏威夷衬衫的胖、嗓门大的希腊人。比利的工作之一是用励志演讲来启发我们。比利会向我们解释当他刚开始在《公报》工作时，他坐的位置和我们一模一样，而现在，他赚的钱和管道工一样多。而且事实上，我们都有机会赚到和管道工一样多的钱。“我今晚要出去吃一块大肥牛排，”他说，“就像管道工结束一天工作后做的那样。”
Eventually, as happens to all the mighty, I fell. Even now, I can't explain it. Hubris, my diet. Perhaps I started taking myself too seriously and lost my sense of fun. Who knows? But whatever the case, I suddenly found myself so desperate for sales that at the end of a shift, still with nothing, I would order the paper to my own address and then cancel it the following week.
最终，正如所有强大的人都会发生的那样，我坠落了。即使是现在，我也无法解释。傲慢，我的饮食。也许我开始把自己看得太重，失去了乐趣感。谁知道呢？但无论如何，我突然发现自己对销售是如此渴望，以至于班次结束时，手里还是什么都没有，我会把报纸订到自己的地址，然后下周取消它。
It's a very real thing, the stink of desperation. It's an actual odor, and people can smell it over the phone line. Your jokes become a little more hurried and forced, your confidence a little more false, your pauses more awkward. I soon found myself gazing longingly at the filled-out order sheets clutched in the fist of the new office superstar, a 17-year-old whose phone name was Candy, who'd stroll past my desk humming "Taking Care of Business."
绝望的恶臭是非常真实的事情。这是一种真实的气味，人们能透过电话线闻到它。你的玩笑变得更加匆忙和生硬，你的自信更加虚假，你的停顿更加尴尬。我很快发现自己渴望地盯着被新办公室超级明星紧紧抓在拳头里的填好的订单表，那是一个17岁的电话名字叫“糖果”的女孩，她哼着《处理业务》走过我的桌子。
Now, when I came back from the bathroom during my shift, Ray would ask me what the hell took so long. The toilet was for closers.
现在，当我在轮班期间从洗手间回来时，雷会问我到底花了这么久在干什么。厕所是给胜出者准备的。
A few weeks ago, I got home and found this on my answering machine.
几周前，我回到家，在答录机上发现了这个。
Hello?
喂？
When the telemarketer realized that there was no one there to pitch to, he stopped himself. But I want you to listen again and notice the long pause before he actually puts the phone down.
当电话营销员意识到没有人可以推销时，他停了下来。但我希望你们再听一遍，注意他在真正放下电话之前的长暂停。
Hello?
喂？
He says hello, he inhales, and before he puts the phone down, he pauses. As someone who's sold over the telephone for close to 10 years, I can tell you that the pause between the hello and the hang up is a moment of reprieve. You start to talk, you realize you've gotten an answering machine, and then before you actually hang up, you steal a moment. You take shelter in those few seconds before you hit the hang up button and the onslaught of automatically dialed phone numbers begins anew, delivering the voices of people who will very soon hate you directly into the earphones of your headset and straight into your brain.
他说了喂，吸了一口气，在放下电话之前，他停顿了一下。作为一个在电话里销售了近10年的人，我可以告诉你，喂和挂断之间的暂停是一个喘息的时刻。你开始说话，意识到你打到了答录机，然后在真正挂断之前，你偷得了一个片刻。你躲在那几秒钟里，在挂断按钮被按下，自动拨号的电话号码洪流再次开始，将很快就会恨你的声音直接传送到你的耳机和你的大脑之前。
I played the message over and over, listening to it, not to better hear the chaos of the pitching room, but to try and imagine what was going through his head. And at the same time, I tried to remember what went through my own head during those pauses. It was always sort of like that moment in a horror film with the guy who's having his head held down in a bathtub of water pops up one last time and goes, [INHALES] before he is pushed back down and is drowned forever.
我反复播放这条信息，倾听它，不是为了更好地听清推销室里的混乱，而是为了试着想象他脑子里在想什么。同时，我试着记住在那些停顿中我自己脑子里在想什么。那总是有点像恐怖电影里那个头被按在浴缸水里的家伙，最后一次浮出水面，吸了一口气，然后被按回去永远溺死的情景。
Since the numbers were automatically dialed, you never knew who was going to pop up in your headset. One time I got my friend Mark Zelnicker on the phone, a guy who I hadn't seen in years. Mark was in my junior high phys ed class. He used to get so excited while playing hog ball that he'd clutch the ball to his chest and roll around the floor drooling.
因为号码是自动拨号的，你永远不知道谁会从你的耳机里跳出来。有一次我拨通了我的朋友马克·泽尔尼克，一个我多年没见的人。马克和我曾在一个初中体育课班级。他以前玩“猪球”时会非常兴奋，以至于把球紧紧抓在胸前，在地上打滚流口水。
I tried to keep him on the phone as long as possible, never saying who I was, gleaning whatever I could about his life. I could hear his kids playing around, trying to steal the phone from him. And all throughout, I was shocked by how unfailingly decent he was with me. I felt like the anonymous stranger who shows up on Christmas Day to test a family's kindness. Mark didn't buy the paper, but he didn't rush me off either. It felt good to know that Mark Zelnicker had grown up to be a really nice man.
我试着尽可能让他多在电话上待一会儿，从不说我是谁，尽可能多地收集关于他生活的信息。我能听到他的孩子们在玩耍，试图从他手里抢电话。自始至终，我对他是如何不折不扣地对我表现得体感到震惊。我觉得自己就像圣诞节那天突然出现去测试一个家庭善良与否的匿名陌生人。马克没买报纸，但他也没匆忙挂断我。知道马克·泽尔尼克长大后成了个真正的好人，感觉很好。
There was also one time I got my grandmother. After several minutes of talking about how weird it was that I had gotten her number out of all the numbers in the city, she told me that she had just learned that morning that my grandfather's cancer had come back. I looked across the room where Billy the manager was eating French fries, and someone else was ringing the bell on Ray's desk.
还有一次我拨通了我祖母的电话。在聊了几分钟关于我竟然从城里所有号码中打给她是多么不可思议之后，她告诉我她那天早上刚得知我祖父的癌症复发了。我看向房间对面，比利经理正在吃炸薯条，有人正在敲响雷桌子上的铃。
After I hung up the phone with her, not a second later, another call popped into my headset. Hi, I'm calling from the Gazette, I said. My grandfather would be dead within the year.
和她挂断电话后，一秒钟都没停，另一个电话就弹进了我的耳机。“嗨，我是《公报》打来的，”我说。我祖父一年内就会去世。
And then one day, I got my own number. I can't explain it better than to say that having that happen is sort of like rounding the corner and running into yourself. At first, you don't quite recognize that it's you. You look a little shorter and less handsome. But then all of a sudden, in one naked instant, you're face to face with yourself. I was the telemarketing dog that had caught its own telemarketing tail.
然后有一天，我拨通了自己的电话号码。我无法更好地解释这件事，只能说发生这种情况有点像转过拐角撞到了自己。起初，你还没认出那是你自己。你看起来有点矮，没那么帅。但突然间，在那赤裸的一瞬间，你和自己面对面了。我就是那条咬住自己电话营销尾巴的电话营销狗。
The message that I left myself, because you just can't resist leaving yourself a message, was something like, yep, here I am. God, this is awful. This is horrible. This has to mean something. But of course, it didn't mean anything. And then for the next several seconds, I listened to the silence on the other end of the line, my own line, as I worried about the rapid fire calls that would start again the moment I hung up.
我留给自己的留言，因为你就是忍不住给自己留个言，大约是这样的：“耶，我在这。天哪，这太糟糕了。这太可怕了。这一定意味着什么。”但当然，它什么也没意味着。然后接下来的几秒钟里，我听着电话线另一端、我自己的那条线上的寂静，我担心着一旦我挂断电话，那种连珠炮式的呼叫又会重新开始。
When I got back home, I had exactly two messages on my machine. One was the message from myself. I was surprised by how loud the background noise was behind me and how much smaller I sounded than I'd imagined all these years. The other message was from my mother. She was imploring me to go back to school and become a speech therapist.
当我回到家时，我的答录机上有两条留言。一条是我留给自己的。我很惊讶背景噪音有那么大，而且听起来比我这些年想象的要渺小得多。另一条是我母亲留的。她恳求我回到学校去当语言治疗师。
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of the podcast, Heavyweight, whose new season starts September 26.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦是播客《重量级》的主持人，该播客新一季将于9月26日开始。
Act Five, The Accursed Items. It's not just human beings who fail to achieve the fate that they thought that fate had in store for them. Most everything does. Most everything eventually ends up somewhere that it was not designed to go, serving a purpose that it was not meant for, even if that purpose is just landfill. We end our program today with this brief inventory from J. Robert Lennon of inanimate objects who have left their Plan A far behind and now inhabit a permanent Plan B.
第五幕：被诅咒的物品。不仅仅是人类未能实现命运认为为他们准备的命运。大多数事物都没有。大多数东西最终都会落在它们本不应该去的地方，服务于它们本不应该服务的目的，即使那个目的只是垃圾填埋场。今天我们以J·罗伯特·伦农的这个简短的清单结束我们的节目，清单列举了那些远离了A计划，现在定居在永久性B计划中的无生命物体。
(HOST) J. ROBERT LENNON: A bottle of pain reliever brought on a business trip that proves, at the moment it is most needed, to be filled not with pain reliever, but with buttons. An accomplished forgery of a famous painting that was thought to have been lost in a 1965 mansion fire, which now hangs in the largest gallery of a major American art museum. Sneakers hanging from the power line, with one-half of a boy's broken glasses stuffed into each toe.
（主持人）J·罗伯特·伦农：一瓶在商务旅行中带来的止痛药，在最需要它的时刻，却发现里面装的不是止痛药，而是纽扣。一幅著名的伪造名画，曾被认为在1965年的豪宅大火中丢失，现在悬挂在美国一家主要艺术博物馆最大的画廊里。挂在电线上的运动鞋，每一只鞋尖里都塞着男孩破损眼镜的一半。
J. Robert Lennon reading a story, The Accursed Items, which is in a collection of stories called See You in Paradise. His latest novel is Broken River.
J·罗伯特·伦农朗读故事《被诅咒的物品》，该故事收录在故事集《天堂见》中。他最新的小说是《破碎的河流》。
[MUSIC - QUASI, "CALIFORNIA"] ACT 6:
（音乐 - Quasi乐队，《California》）第六幕：
Bite it like you mean it. Like cave woman.
咬住它，就像你真的想要一样。像个穴居女人。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周继续带来更多《美国生活》的故事。